there's great news coming out of the
media right now which is that
kyle rittenhouse
the alleged white supremacist terrorist
worst man in america remember joe biden
called him a white supremacist in his
campaign ad well kyle rittenhouse
who in reality is a teenager who
defended himself against antifa
thugs
who was then exonerated in court kyle
rittenhouse is launching something
called the media accountability project
to hold
the
mainstream
legacy establishment call it what you
want media to account for their lies
me and my team have decided to launch
the media accountability project as a
tool to help fundraise and hold the
media accountable for the lies they said
and deal with them in court
interesting so the idea is
maybe like the covington catholic kids
you will be suing news organizations
that maliciously lie about people who
are in the news
is that the plan
yes sir we're going to be holding them
accountable tucker
do you exp i mean i guess i have to ask
a kind of a dumb question but you know
why isn't there a group like this that
exists already since the media so often
are not observers they're players
they're participants
in the news
why hasn't someone done this before
that's a good question tucker and i'm
not sure to be honest but
i don't want to see anybody else have to
deal with what i went through so i want
to hold them accountable for what they
did to me because i don't want to see
anybody have to go through what i went
through
this is great i really applaud kyle
rittenhouse as a historical matter this
actually has been done before and not a
lot of people remember this but the
people who did it is us we not the daily
wire but the organization that existed
just before the daily wire was kind of
the precursor organization it was called
truth revolt it was i didn't even work
for truth revolt directly i was i was
friends with the guys when they did it
but it was ben and jeremy and drew
actually had this company called truth
revolt and it was not just a media
outlet that would produce videos and
commentary and news articles they would
actively go after media figures who were
spreading lies who were who were pushing
a radical leftist agenda and and they
would they were sort of like immediate
matters for the right and it existed for
a while then it sort of morphed into the
daily wire and the rest is history but
it's really important i'm glad that an
organization like this now exists
rittenhouse is absolutely right the
reason is there is no such thing as
freedom of the press in america
there is no free press
in america
you we hear the hand ringing and the
pearl clutching and the sorkin watching
liberals they say no freedom of the
press where the journalists are under
attack it's not we don't have freedom of
the press and the reason we don't have
freedom of the press is frankly because
of our press
and because of our technology apparatus
and because of our government
working in tandem with these private
corporations go to goodranchers.com
knowles right now do it right now you
are going to thank me later i love these
guys okay i am something of a meat
aficionado
all right i i eat red meat almost every
single day i know it's not going to be
good i'm probably going to get gout in
any day now but i love it and i've got
very exacting standards good ranchers
has phenomenal meat it's by the way it's
not just red meat either i had their
chicken the other night grilled it up
the chicken is magnificent they've got
lots of different seasonings and things
and then the beef is just wonderful the
steaks are great the hamburgers are
great
i've got a freezer full of this stuff
it's 100 american meat so not only is it
delicious but unlike that meat you're
getting in the grocery store this meat
is actually supporting american ranchers
okay and it's also supporting this show
so if you like this show it's it's not
uh it's not easy for advertisers always
to support conservative
podcasts and conservative causes so i
really give these guys a lot of credit
they're supporting good old-fashioned
american values and they have an amazing
product to boot head on over to
goodranchers.com
knowles today
they've got a whole bunch of different
subscriptions you can get a whole bunch
of different boxes you can order one off
right now if you use code knowles you
can get 30 bucks off your box now is the
time go head over to goodranchers.com
knowles today you will thank me later
i'm glad you like that clip now here's
what you got to do
ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications for all the videos that
come out also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
that is the
m-i-c-h-a-e-l space k-n-w-l-e-s space
s-h-o-w subscribe leave a five-star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you